let's say that you started off with
three apples and then I were to give you
another seven another seven apples so my
question to you and this might be very
obvious is how many apples how many
apples do you now have and I'll give you
a second to think about that well this
is fairly basic you had three apples now
I'm going to give you seven more you now
have three plus seven you now have ten
apples but let's say I want to do the
same type of thinking but I'm too lazy
to write the word apples let's say
instead of writing the word apples I
just use the letter A and I say let's
say and this is say a different scenario
you start off with four apples you start
off with four apples and to that I add
another two apples I add another two
apples how many apples do you now have
instead of writing apples I'm just going
to write a zero so how many of these A's
do you now have and once again I'll give
you a few seconds to think about that
well this also might be a little bit of
common sense for you if you had four of
these apples or whatever these a is
represented via four of them and then
you add two more of them you're now
going to have six of these apples but
once again we started off assuming that
A's represent apples but they could have
represented anything if you have four of
whatever a represents and then you have
another two of whatever a represents
you'll now have six of whatever a
represents or if you just think of it if
I have four A's and then I add another
two A's I'm going to have six a is you
can literally think of for A's as a plus
a plus a plus a and if I do that if to
that I add another two A's
so plus a plus a that's two A's right
over there
how many A's do I now have well that's
one two three four five six
I now have six A's so thinking of it
that way let's get a little bit more
abstract let's say that I have five X's
whatever X represents X could be some
number so I have five of whatever that
number is
and from that I subtract I subtract two
of what
that number is what would this evaluate
to how many of these exes how many of
these X is what I now have
so it's essentially 5 X minus 2 X is
going to be what times X now once again
I'll give you a few seconds to think
about it
well if I have five of something and I
subtract two of those away I'm going to
have three of that something left so
this is going to be equal to 3 X 5 X
minus 2 X is equal to 3 X and if you
really think about what that means five
X's are just X plus X plus X plus X plus
X and then we're going to take away two
of those X's we're going to take away 2
X's so take away 1 X take away 2 X's you
are left you are going to be left with 3
x's